E
COULD HAVE OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
VERY VULNERABLE RIGHT NOW OF
SIMULTANEOUS ATTACKS.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS EXPOSING HOW VULNERABLE
WE ARE, DAVID.
THANK YOU.
>>> THIS MORNING, HOUSE
REPUBLICANS PLAN TO REMOVE
CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ CHENEY FROM
HER LEADERSHIP POSITION FOR
OPPOSING FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
CHENEY HAS BEEN AT ODDS WITH GOP
MEMBERS SINCE VOTING TO IMPEACH
MR. TRUMP IN JANUARY.
ON THE HOUSE FLOOR LAST NIGHT,
SHE SAID REPUBLICANS WHO SUPPORT
PHONY CLAIMS OF A STOLEN
ELECTION ARE A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
>> I AM A CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICAN, AND THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE OF CONSERVATIVE
PRINCIPLES IS REVERENCE FOR THE
RULE OF LAW.
THE ELECTION IS OVER.
THAT IS THE RULE OF LAW.
THAT IS OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
PROCESS.
THOSE WHO REFUSE TO ACCEPT THE
RULINGS OF OUR COURTS ARE AT WAR
WITH THE CONSTITUTION.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT POLICY.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT PARTISANSHIP.
THIS IS ABOUT OUR DUTY AS
AMERICANS.
REMAINING SILENT AND IGNORING
THE LIE EMBOLDENS THE LIAR.
I WILL NOT PARTICIPATE IN THAT.
I WILL NOT SIT BACK AND WATCH IN
SILENCE WHILE OTHERS LEAD OUR
PARTY DOWN A PATH THAT ABANDONS
THE RULE OF LAW AND JOINS THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S CRUSADE TO
UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> CHIEF WASHINGTON
CORRESPONDENT MAJOR GARRETT
JOINS US NOW.
MAJOR, GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> HOW SIGNIFICANT IS THIS VOTE?
>> LET ME GIVE YOU A TWO-PART
ANSWER.
FOR EVERYDAY AMERICANS IT IS NOT
SIGNIFICANT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
NUMBER-THREE LEADER IN THE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WHICH IS THE
MINORITY PARTY IN THE HOUSE.
THIS IS NO ASPERSIONS AGAINST
THE REPUBLICANS, BUT THAT'S LIKE
THE THIRD-STRING QUARTERBACK ON
THE JC HIGH SCHOOL FOOTBALL
TEAM.
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY POWER IN THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES, AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
NUMBER-THREE LEADER.
FOR AMERICANS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHETHER THEY SHOULD BUY A
GALLON OF GAS OR WORRIED ABOUT
INFLATION, THIS DOES NOT AFFECT
THEIR LIFE.
SYMBOLICALLY IT IS MASSIVELY
IMPORTANT.
WHY?
BECAUSE LIZ CHENEY IN THAT
SPEECH AND HER OVERALL REMARKS
IN THE LAST THREE WEEKS IS
LAYING DOWN A MARKER.
THE MARKER IS THIS -- EITHER YOU
BELIEVE IN THE CONSTITUTION,
FEDERALISM, THE WAY WE CONDUCT
OUR ELECTIONS, AND THAT THIS
ELECTION IS ACTUALLY OVER, OR
YOU DON'T.
AND IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE THAT,
YOU'RE GOING TO VOTE ME OUT OF
OFFICE.
THE KIND OF A RITUAL LIKE SHE'S
BEING STONED OR BURNED AT THE
STAKE.
SHE WANTS TO BE, SHE WANT
THENITION TO SEE THIS MOMENT --
THE NATION TO SEE THIS MOMENT
FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY FOR
WHAT SHE SAYS IT IS -- A
DIVIDING LINE BETWEEN TRUTH AND
FICTION.
>> WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR THE
PARTY SYMBOLICALLY GOING FORWARD
THEN, MAJOR?
>> IT DEPENDS.
LIZ CHENEY'S LONG-TERM BET IS
ALL OF THIS STUFF THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS ABOUT THE
ELECTION WILL OVER TIME FADE
AWAY AND BECOME LESS TOXIC AND
LESS POISONOUS TO THE RANK AND
FILE RANKST HOUSE REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE.
THAT'S HER LONG-TERM BET.
SHE'S GOING TO LOSE THAT TODAY.
BUT SHE BELIEVES ONCE THAT
WASHES THROUGH THE PARTY AND
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NO
LONGER AS RELEVANT AS HE IS NOW,
SHE CAN RISE UP AND THE
ANTI-TRUMP FACTION CAN RISE UP.
THAT'S A LONG-TERM BET.
RIGHT NOW SHE'S GOING TO LOSE IT
BECAUSE EVERYONE IN THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS WHO TODAY
VOTES HER OUT WILL BE VOTING
WITH DONALD TRUMP, AND BY PROXY,
WITH THE BIG LIE.
>> I HEAR YOU, BUT IT'S A SECRET
BALLOT.
SO I STILL AM TRYING TO WRAP MY
BRAIN AROUND THE FACT THAT SHE
IS PROBABLY GOING TO BE OUSTED
FOR TELLING THE TRUTH.
SOMETHING ALL THESE GUYS
PROBABLY TELL THEIR CHILDREN --
TELL THE TRUTH.
>> YEP.
>> IS IT UNREALISTIC OR NAIVE TO
THINK THAT BECAUSE IT IS A
SECRET BALLOT THAT MAYBE, JUST
MAYBE SHE COULD PULL IT OUT
TODAY?
>> I THINK IT'S HIGHLY, HIGHLY
UNLIKELY.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT HER PEOPLE
WHO WORK CLOSELY WITH HER ARE
ANTICIPATING OTHER THAN BEING
DRIVEN OUT OF OFFICE.
HER OVERALL ATTITUDE ABOUT THIS
IS THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN, BUT
I WANT EVERYONE TO SEE IT AS IT
HAPPENS, SORT OF A SLOW-MOTION
MARKER FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AND THIS IS AN INTERESTING
DYNAMIC, GAYLE.
I WAS HERE IN WASHINGTON
COVERING NEWT GINGRICH BACK IN
THE EARLY '90s.
HE WAS THE MOST POWERFUL
REPUBLICAN IN 1994 WHEN HE
BROUGHT HOUSE REPUBLICANS TO
THEIR FIRST MAJORITY IN 40
YEARS.
IT WAS INCONCEIVABLE THAT ONLY
FOUR YEARS LATER HIS OWN HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WOULD THROW HIM OUT
OF THE SPEAKERSHIP.
THEY DID, WHY?
BECAUSE HE BECAME A PROBLEM IN
THEIR HOME DISTRICTS.
THEY WERE TIRED OF EXPLAINING
NEWT GINGRICH.
PRO-TRUMP HOUSE REPUBLICANS WANT
TO SAY WE GOT RID OF THIS PERSON
WHO DISAGREES WITH TRUMP, AND
THAT'S HOW I PROVE MY SOLIDITY
TO YO